[Music]
[Music]
hello
i'm jeffrey lessel uh you can call me
geo i am the author of phoenix in action
and i'm super excited that you are here
with me today um we are taking over the
manning live
stream twitch channel which is pretty
fun
uh we're gonna be going over some things
today with the elixir programming
language
and phoenix the phoenix web framework
and
to be honest i'm kind of excited about
this i'm looking forward to
seeing what you guys have in terms of
questions for me we're going to try to
do this somewhat interactively
so if you have questions please let me
know what they are
and um we'll go from there which is
going to be pretty awesome
the first thing we where i want to tell
you about is
my information i guess
this is who i am i'm geo i'm jeffrey
lessel
and um you can find me
at these different uh locations online
i'm on twitter
uh at geolessel i am um on github at
geolessel
i blog at jeffreylessel.com
and i have a youtube channel which i've
been doing some live streaming on
recently
and some live coding uh typically more
in the lisp
language for emacs uh just configuring
my emacs programming or emacs
environment to get exactly how i want
but
i'm considering doing some things with
um with elixir on there too soon so
that'll be fun
now um i also want to let you know that
if you have not picked up a copy of my
book yet
then there is a code twit less
40 and that gets you 40 off everything
at manning.com which is pretty cool
if you go to phoenixinaction.com it'll
take you straight
to um the the website
where you can purchase it so let me show
you like if i just go to phoenix
in action.com it'll take you right to
the page
and it tacks on a little thing that
gives me just a little bit extra money
because i sent you there which would be
super nice
uh so add that to your cart use the code
twitles40
and get 40 off um and thank you
that's kind of a thank you for coming
and joining us today
um i need to bring up the chat here um
because i cannot see it so let me bring
that up
i'm hoping that it'll be easy to do i've
done this on youtube quite a bit but not
a whole lot
on twitch so i apologize um if i am not
the twitch king
um which you know maybe i am maybe i'm
not
all right so what are we gonna do today
we are going to be building
a real-time chat application uh with
alien
with elixir and phoenix and
particularly with a module in phoenix
called live view which is really cool
it allows like phoenix on its own was
really good for real-time
communication between the client and the
server well and elixir itself was
built for that on top of erlang so it's
it's
on its own really good for that but then
phoenix live view
takes that and takes to the next level
which is really cool
um so we're going to be utilizing that
to create some really cool stuff
um let me bring up see make sure you can
see my uh
my editor there yeah here's our editor
so we're going to be going from
i've got nothing um in terms of code
installed yet i i have
um kind of gone through this a little
bit on my own just to see
what it would take and see if we could
do it within an hour it'll probably take
a little more than an hour
um but hopefully you'll stick around and
we can get it done together um
and by the way if you if you want to i
can't see the chat now so if you want to
say hi or ask any questions i'm just
going to put that in the chat
i'll get to those when i see them come
up um if i'm not so
laser focused on getting this code in uh
so
the first thing we need to do is we need
to start a new elixir application
so if you guys have not done this before
uh it's super easy and
the cool thing about elixir is it
provides some really good help even in
the command line so if i just do like
mix phoenix new
it'll print out a whole bunch of
information about the options that we
have
um how to configure the application in
terms of the generator
so in this case you know this command
creates a new phoenix project
and expects the path of the project as
an argument a project
a given path will be created and the
application name and module name will be
retrieved from the path
unless module or app is given and that
way we can kind of specify exactly what
we want things to be named
it also has some options so dash live
which includes the phoenix live view
module to make it easier than ever to
build interactive real-time applications
a little plug in there for phoenix live
view
in the help which is pretty fun umbrella
which creates a number of applications
so you kind of keep your business logic
and um your web interface for that
separate um and maybe even include other
interfaces in there as well
uh and then the name of the otp
application and the module
the base module and then what kind of
database you're going to use um
i'm going to go through a couple of
these first of all this dash live we are
going to be creating a phoenix live view
application so we'll go ahead and pass
this stash live it does a few things for
us that makes things
quite a bit easier when we're creating
an application um so that's nice
the other thing we're going to be doing
is we are going to be doing no database
so um the idea behind the chat
application is
it's going to be basically zero
configuration chat
for the for the end user so you don't
log in you don't even
have to like manually create a room to
chat in you basically just go to a url
and start chatting
now there's some some downsides to that
one is um your username will be
generated automatically and randomly
so you won't be able to choose that but
um you know if you wanted to take this
id and run with it in a different
direction you could of course
allow account creations reserve
usernames for certain individuals that
kind of thing certain accounts
so but today we're just going to do
random usernames and go from there
so no database though um no webpack so
that basically just says you know i'm
not going to be doing this
with some javascript or if i am i need
to manually handle it myself like move
brunch or some other packaging
asset building management system
whatever
no ecto so that's what we're going to be
doing we don't want to generate ecto
files
and ecto is a really good package to
help you manage your database
connections
and since we're going to have no
database we're going to say no ecto and
that's going to take care of the node
database stuff that we were talking
about
no html do not generate html views we we
do want html stuff
git text dashboard i'll show you a
little bit about phoenix live dashboard
possibly once we get into it
it's pretty cool but we do want
dashboard that's kind of fun and it
doesn't
really um there's no benefit to not
including it for us
uh binary id that's primary key for
ectotypes you're not going to be using
ectos
or ecto so not not a big deal and then
verbose
um and then some examples down here just
a little more
text but well let's get into it so we
want to do mix phoenix new
uh we're going to do live and we're
going to know ecto
and let's call our application chat
super creative i know i came up with
that on my own
um i put a poll out i'm just kidding
let's just name it chat
um oh no echo so it's not echo friendly
but we do want no ecto
so it'll it created all that from our
generator and we told it to go ahead and
install
and fetch the dependencies so it's going
to do that
and while it's doing that
well let's just let that finish because
it's not going to take long and the next
thing to do is
on the command line as well so um
let's talk about how we're going to
generate i mentioned that we're going to
be generating
the uh the chat rooms names
dynamically or the usernames dynamically
and you can essentially create a
chatroom on the fly
and one of the things we're going to be
one of the ways we're going to be able
to do that
is by using a package
called mmonomic
slugs man that word is so hard to say
for me
um but we're going to be using that to
um to generate
some random slug information some random
urls
uh so that'll be nice to have um
from there um
[Music]
man this is taking a little longer than
i was expecting which is unfortunate
but i'll tell you what let's go ahead
and look at manamic slugs um
so let's go to github over here
github and there's a cool
um website called awesome elixir that i
go to a lot to check out
new packages or or if i'm looking for
something
that uh that does a specific thing i can
go here and find that
so this is monomi slugs um well search
for that
minomic slugs a memorable mnemonic
slug generator and elixir so if we look
in there i'm gonna get a little give us
a little bit information about how to
use it
and um and what it is so
it'll essentially you can tell it how
many slugs you want
and it'll generate a string with that
many
uh of those slugs in there which is
pretty cool and that's how we're going
to be generating our random usernames
um we're also going to allow the user to
if they
don't can't think of their own chat room
name we'll allow them just to create a
random
room and uh that will be
handled the random room name will be
handled by this package as well
um i think i can
like i'm the stream
my view of the stream keeps pausing i
hope it's not messing up for you
um so i paused it on twitch for me i'm
hoping that this
the chat still streams through so i can
see your uh questions or comments as
they come in
um and we'll go from there so um let's
check our status
of our install and it's still going
that is unfortunate
um let's go ahead and cancel that for
now uh
let's go into our chat um directory
and um
let's go and start up a server and see
what that looks like so we have done
nothing in terms of configuration of the
server
um let's see if it actually has
installed the assets and for some reason
it was just hanging
okay so now it's going to compile the
elixir um and
if you didn't know elixir is a compiled
language which uh makes it
fast it compiles down to beam
the beam vm byte code
and essentially it goes through
erlang as well and erlang is a really
cool language
all right calib again this is taking a
long time
um let me check to see what is eating up
on my
processing power and i'll be right back
okay
back sorry about that delay um i have
checked and it looks like
it was potentially the
my backup software this stream is also
being recorded to disk so
the backup was just eating up the uh
the processing power all right so
let's go to our local host and see what
we have here so localhost 4000
and we have phoenix it is live
um it is usable we can do things in it
which is cool so it's got this live
dashboard thing
um in there it shows you some stats
about your running application
including like uptime and your output
your input
ports processes all this real-time
information that you can get about your
application
uh which is pretty neat but we're not
going to spend a whole lot of time in
there
um we're going to spend most of our time
out here
all right uh so within here um this is
essentially the
what the generator produces for us in
terms of html we don't
want most of this we want to really get
rid of it so let's just strip all that
out
and go from there so let me open up the
[Music]
the application here so it's going to be
in lib chat web
and from in there it's going to be under
templates and then layout
and then root is going to be one of them
this is where the navigation like the
header stuff is
and uh let me turn off flightcheck mode
and um format all buffer mode
uh so within here we can remove this
header um and we can just say i don't
know
h1 phoenix in action
chat how about that
and then the inner content renders what
um the specific
view or the specific route renders which
is nice so
you can see that now we have phoenix in
action chat let me back that out just a
little bit because i think this section
container has
information that we're going to want so
let's let's do it in here
phoenix and action chat let's see if
that works better
because i kind of want that centered
there we go perfect
also phoenix has an auto reload
mechanism so once it recognizes that
there's been some code changes it'll
automatically reload the application uh
without you having to do anything
and it is not um that uncommon
for the um
for the web page to have them reloaded
before i'm even
able to come to the app back to the web
page which is pretty crazy
all right so um let's check this we're
going to quit that because what we're
going to do next is
include that manaomic slugs package now
that's
we have things compiled so
that we do things um in terms of
packages in the mix.exe file
and everything is like everything is
configured here in this project
function and you can see the depths
that's our dependencies if we go down
and then it runs the depths
function so if we go down here to the
depth function
we can see these are all the
dependencies that our application
depends on at the moment we want to add
another one here
of minomic slugs
slugs
man that is so hard for me to say and
spell so we're at 0.0.3 on this package
so we want to make sure to get that one
or anything above that within the point
release so we can say
mixdepts.get and that'll fetch that
package for us
and then we'll restart the server again
and the next time we've restarted it
we'll have that
package started with this so
let's do mix phoenix.server and it'll
recompile a little bit because it's got
to recompile that monomic slugs
in for us um so there it is compiling
anomic slugs
and while it's recompiling let's also
clear out
um on our webpage here this little area
right here is welcome to phoenix
all that we don't need that that's not
something that that we need so
let's clear that out and that is in um
a template directory template and
uh since we we have we don't know this
yet but
um phoenix when it generates the code it
creates a page controller and it routes
uh the
the root route goes to this page
controller so our template is going to
be
um templates.page dot index or page
index
and i'm gonna it's trying to look at
every single
my pat my um
create a git repository here
because whenever i try to find a file it
tries to
find every file in there including
things like
node modules and things like that so as
long as i create a repository it should
ignore those things for me
um so yeah that's gonna be a lot faster
so if we go to page
pagelive.html.lex and look in there
this is all that um that html that's
generating that box and that search uh
thing and all that so let's get rid of
this
and also disable um
format all mode all right so we're just
gonna say goodbye to this
save it and hopefully we've got
recompiled yes so
as you can see again i beat it beat me
to get back to the to the reload
so we have nothing again which is
perfect that's what we wanted we wanted
nothing
so now we have nothing let's add
something now the first thing we're
going to add is just a little button to
allow a user to go to a random url so
let's try that
if we go back to our our session here
you'll notice i started the server with
that iex
capital s mix phoenix server and that
allows us to go into an iex
reppel and if you're familiar with
elixir if you're not familiar with
elixir iex is essentially the rebel for
elixir and even though it's a compiled
language it does some you know on the
fly compiling to
and then run the code which is nice um
but we can use the things that we've
compiled in here so if we go to monomic
and then slugs
and then you can even press tab and it
has a lot of completion so we can say
generate slug
and maybe like three of them and so now
we have rose sahara
citizen cool so that's pretty neat but
we want to use this
on maybe like a button that would take
the user to that random url
um so let's create a button a button a
button
we've got the button um so i'm just back
in this blank
pagelive.html.lex file
and um first thing we want to do is i'm
just going to say a title is create a
random room
uh and create a random
room and we'll see what that looks like
save it
there's our button right now if we click
on it nothing happens because we haven't
added any
any action to it or anything like that
now phoenix provides our phoenix live
view specifically provides some
listeners
and some form handlers things like that
so we can go in and
attach phoenix live view listeners to
specific events in the browser in this
case we want to listen for a click
on this button so we say phoenix click
and when we
listen when we hear that click we're
going to go to the random room
or we're going to send the random room
event to our server
so now if i click it you're gonna notice
that my my um
did you see my precursor spin just a
little bit there that's because
if we look in the um the logs the server
actually crashed
the process that's running this phoenix
live view that contains this phoenix
live view process crashed
because we haven't defined a function
matching
in uh page live and chat web that page
live
now you may be wondering what is page
live let me go to the routes or the
router
file and in here you can see how phoenix
will handle
a request to our server in this case
it pipes it through this browser which
handles a bunch of things in terms of
plugs like you know fetching the session
touching flash protecting from forgery
that type of stuff but the thing we're
interested in
here is this scope here so scope slash
means at the root level
we're going to be in the chat web um
kind of namespace we're going to pipe
all these requests through this browser
pipeline that we see
above and finally within the slash we
anything that goes to slash from there
we want to send a page live and then the
index
action so let's look in page live in
here
you can see um we have a few different
functions defined for us and again this
was just made by the generator
and a lot of this we're going to we're
going to delete here in a second but one
thing we want to keep
is this mount function every time
someone requests
the a new web page from us um phoenix
live view will run this mount action to
mount the page in terms of the socket
the live connection to for the user so
we're going to keep that
but this suggests search all that kind
of stuff we don't want
so let's just go and delete that but
what we do want is to handle
that click so we can just say this is
this impul true is basically saying yes
this is an implementation
um we're implementing a function in this
case uh so make sure that
it kind of basically gives you some
extra error handling and messaging for
that
which is nice so we can say
def and go back to the um
the error here we can kind of see how we
need to define this so it says
the um the function that was called was
this page live handle event with this
random room as the first argument
remember what we told phoenix to do when
we pressed that click was to send an
event named random room
to our server and so we need to handle
that event now
the second option or the second
parameter is a list of params and in
this case there are none so we can
ignore them
and then finally all the events sent to
uh phoenix are going to be through
socket connections or
well the socket information and that's
something we need to carry on throughout
the process of
the connection so we're going to handle
this socket as well and we'll show you
how to do that in a second
all right so let's define that handle
event random room and
the first thing is first we define the
function name and then another cool
thing about elixir if you're not
familiar with it is it provides pattern
matching
pattern matching on your function
definitions so you can have multiple
handle events
and each one can handle a different
event in this case we need to handle the
random room event so
whenever a handle event is called where
the message is sent to
this process it's going to look through
all the handle events and find one that
says okay this is the first one
of the ones that are defined that
matches so we're going to match on
random room we don't care about the
parameters
but we do care about the socket so like
in
many programming languages if you uh
precede a um
a uh a variable with an underscore that
basically tells elixir that
you don't really care about about what
it is now if i had done this and just
not used it then elixir's compiler would
warn us about that said hey you've got
this variable that you're not using that
you haven't preceded with an underscore
do you really want to use it
and if not maybe just go ahead and
pre-see that with an underscore so let's
do that
now handle event expects a certain type
of
return value in this case we're just
going to say no reply and socket
now the no reply basically means don't
reply to the sender of the message
and in this case we don't want to reply
to the center of the message
because that's another process we're
just going to pass that straight on
through
and the socket is what tells um
tells phoenix what to do now with that
socket so
since phoenix basically kind of re-loops
on itself and handles that process and
goes over and over and over
and say what's the new state of the
socket what's the new state of the
socket what's the new state of the
socket
and in this case we're just saying the
state of the socket was the exact same
as the city of the socket you gave us a
minute ago and we're going to change
that in a minute but i'll show you what
happens if we just define it like this
so i'm going to save that now when i go
and click this
we don't have that spinning cursor
anymore and
the server doesn't crash in fact we can
hear there's no crashing on the server
if we wanted to we could log that out in
fact let's just go ahead and do that i
i'm kind of a logger guy i like to just
see things in my logs
as i'm debugging so it's likely we're
going to need a logger in there
anyway so in this case let's just say
logger info um
click and save that and we can show you
that indeed we are handling that click
event so i'll click that go back to our
terminal and yes you can see in our logs
now we have info
click perfect now what do we need to do
to send the uh
the user on their way to a random
[Music]
random page random chat room well this
is where that manomic slugs come in
comes in excuse me we can say that um
like a random slug equals
mnemonic slugs mnemonic
slug generate slugs
and in this case let's do maybe a four
string or four word slug
sure why not and then let's um we can
just log out the slug here
i'll show you that make sure that works
click that uh we did get a crash there
let's see what that is
oh no that was still reloading my bad so
let's try it now click it
and here is our random slug we've got
cactus gloria martin family
that's a beautiful chatroom name now we
want to
now redirect the user to a
path that has this in it that would be
their chatroom path
so our random slug is going to be that
plus
the initial slash because that would be
the path um so we're gonna
this little left uh less than greater
than symbol basically means
concatenate so we're concatenating the
string of slug sorry of the slash
with the the generated slug um so now if
i save this
well you can imagine if i click on the
button now after it reloads
click on the button you can see that we
do indeed have the slash now in front of
our generated slug
so let us now redirect the user there
now
i mentioned earlier that um when we
return the socket it basically tells
phoenix live view what to do with the
connection
and phoenix live view provides something
called a function called
push redirect and it takes the socket as
its first argument so we're going to say
for this socket push a redirect to the
slug
so we're going to basically say go to
this path now
and i bet you can guess what's going to
happen when
we save this we press the button and
we'll see
we have an error undefont function slug
now that may be because that's because i
didn't say random slug that's not the
error that i was expecting
so let's do that random slug um save
that
and reload here oh actually i didn't
even press reload again phoenix knows
that uh i saved it so i reloaded for me
i go to random slug we can see that we
were redirected
to this panther silk empire special url
but we don't have anything that's
handling that request
there's no router that that handles that
which is
something we need to define so if you're
just joining us
thanks for for coming in i'm jeffrey
lessel wrote phoenix in action
for manning and um go to
phoenixinaction.com
and if you uh put in this the code twit
less 40 that's 40 off of anything i'm
manning not just my book
but uh hopefully you pick up my book
while you're there um
so let me know in the chat if you have
any questions if we're going through
this there's some contact info on the
page there
on the screen there as well um so uh
go through and and hit me up wherever
you are
all right let's get back to coding now
um we need to handle this request now we
need to say
now that um the request has been made we
need to
go to the the new url
uh in this case we need to go to
our routes our router file and um
right now we're matching on this live
slash basically says anytime
there's um any uh request for this
slash page we're gonna be handled by
page live
but instead we want to um go and
um handle anything else so it's
basically gonna be like a wild card
um it's going to catch everything else
and so we can say uh within here
um we're going to also be a live path
and we're going to use this slash and
then a colon
and then we're going to this is up to us
we're just going to name it id
and let's call this room live we're
going to create a module called room
live to handle all this
and again we'll have the index action
now
id what that will do is anytime we
request something with a slash in front
of it
um uh anything after that it'll be
put into a parameter called id for us so
that we can then use that
to um to
do something we need to do later which
is to subscribe to the channel's
notifications
which we'll get into in a little bit but
for now let's just do this live
id room live index and again if i
reload here at this at this page
we'll notice that we get a different
error now that room live
is undefined so we need to create this
room live
handler i'm going to split the page here
and go back to our page live because we
can actually
copy and paste some of this into our new
module so i'm going to close that and
open up a new one uh oh yeah on chatweb
and then live and then room live.ex
paste that instead of page live i'm
going to change this to room live
it's going to use live view we're going
to go ahead and put logger in there
and for the mount um for now we're just
going to pass
this socket right on um with none of
these parameters
and then these are signs rather and i'll
talk about those a bit more later we're
not going to handle any events on this
page yet because there are going to be
no events
yet and in params as i mentioned
now we'll have the param of id passed
along
and again this is where some of the
pattern matching functionality and
elixir comes through
because we can pattern match on uh the
parameters
that come through so we know the id is
going to be our room id so we'll just
say
the only thing we care about in the
session at this point or sorry in the
params at this point is the room id
now the session we don't care about
either at the moment um
and we're just going to pass the socket
right on through and return okay so when
mount actually expects an okay if things
have gone
as expected when it mounts so i'm going
to save that and again we'll get
probably a different error as it reloads
here
indeed it says render one was not
implemented for chat web room live
so we need to say what do we want to
what we want the
um the server to render when someone
comes to this url
so we need to define um the room live
dot html dot l e e x now l
e e x basically means it's a live elixir
template um
which kind of mixes up the html and the
templating stuff which is pretty cool
so what are we going to say in our um
but for now let's just say hi mom
and see what we get make sure oh man
this is what i get for the uh the format
all thing
format all mode off light check off okay
now let's say hi mom bring back up our
browser
and so now we have hi mom which is neat
now what
if we wanted to let the user know um
because we're cool like that we want to
let them know what room they're chatting
in
and their username for now we don't know
user names we're not going to worry
about that but we are but we do know
already
that they're at this panther silk empire
special chat room
um so let's let them know that that's
where they are so we can say
uh i don't know maybe currently chatting
in and um we have this assign we will
have this assigned we don't have it yet
but we'll call it room id
uh and um let's do like that we'll
make this strong as well strong
all right let's see what that looks like
it's going to crash because we haven't
defined the room id
assign um
let's see did that save yeah
all right room id not available in the
eex template so why is that what is room
id so room id isn't a sign
if you're familiar with other web
frameworks and templating things
um you can it's actually the variable
that the
controller sends on to the view in this
case we don't have a controller as such
but we have this live view which acts
kind of like a controller
um as the the process so let's define
that room id um let's go back to our
page live.eex let me split the page here
again so you can see both the same time
so over on the right you can see our
html and then on the left is
uh our live view
function or our iphone module so when we
mount we have the room id we're not
doing anything with the room id at the
moment
what we can do is we can assign to the
socket
um an assigned variable called room id
and
its value is going to be what we pulled
out
from the function definition which is
room id so now if i save this
um live view will will assign to the
socket
um the variable room id and we're going
to use that now
in the rendering on the web page so now
we can say currently chatting in panther
silk empire special
yay uh so let's um start sliding this up
a little bit i am not a css person so
my styles are going to be lacking
you're going to be able to do things
much better than i would
um but that is okay um okay so
um let's make like a chat container um
because
we're going to before we do it let's
let's make the chat container
let's make it first on the page let's
put it on the page um
so we have the currently chatting let's
go ahead and add a div and
name it uh chat container
container and in there we're gonna have
uh like a messages div
um and there we'll say say chat goes
here for now because we have no chat yet
um we're just making it look the way it
should look and close those divs
save that and let's see what it looks
like now so chat goes here yay so now
let's
make that just a little bit more
visible so we're going to make this
display flex um to put the border on
there i'll pick solid and maybe
something gray-ish
uh how many c is that one more c sure uh
yeah there we go
and then padding let's add in the
padding in there and then margin
uh we're gonna do negative one at the
top
uh one at the right and then
one bottom and then negative one at the
right
i'm gonna put an m in here and then like
a flex direction
uh this will be we're gonna have the uh
the chat
input at the bottom so let's just say
where the chat direction is gonna be
call on here so to line it up one on top
of the other
and uh just by the content as um
space between that'll put a lot the
space in between the things
and then let's just set the height um a
solid value or a
static value for now and then for chat
messages
which is uh inside we want to grow that
as big as it can get
and right now it'll be plenty big
because we don't have anything other
than
chat messages so that's gonna be what it
looks like so we'll just put our chat in
there at the bottom down here
probably we'll put the um the input
field uh and then on the right we'll
eventually put um we'll use presence
phoenix presence which is really fun
and it tracks user activity across your
distributed application which is really
nice
um but we'll put on like who's online
who's in the channel at the moment
um and that'll be on the right over here
somewhere uh again that'll probably look
ugly
but that's what we've got all right so
let's let's create
a form for inputting chat
speaking of chat let me uh look real
quick see if there's any chat going on
um no just uh mailing this information
yeah sign up for manning's mailing list
it's pretty cool
all right so uh we're gonna do it inside
this chat container for now
are we yeah why not um so
we're gonna say f equals form four and
like most
uh web frameworks phoenix has some form
builder helpers
and other functions you can use to to
build
forms um so form four is one of those
and we're going to call the form chat
and for the action we're going to have
it be no action at this moment
because we're going to do it all through
phoenix live view now phoenix live view
it like you may ask
like what if the user has javascript
disabled and
um in the promo videos i mentioned that
we are actually not going to be writing
any javascript today which is insane if
you think about it
that um it's wild that we've got
this crazy real-time um interactive
website this chat
but we're not going to write any of the
javascript it's all going to be server
rendered and
um live view has already has the the
tools in place
to communicate to the server and the
client
as needed which is pretty pretty fun
all right so um no but you can the
reason i mentioned that is because you
can fall back to an html route if you
need to
in this case we're not going to then
we're going to say this
we're going to put an id of chat form on
here just so we can track it with our
css
um and then phoenix i mentioned earlier
that phoenix has
those those hooks that they can you can
log in you can hook on to to to do
callbacks or handle messages to messages
one of those for forums is phoenix
submit um
and we can just say we call this one
submit message
submit chat submit message submit
message um
and then uh let's see do anything else
in there i don't think so
let's go with that then we need a text
input
uh we'll call this the uh it's gonna be
for the
f variable because we're saying f is the
form for chat so um
f and then in there it's gonna be the
message and then we'll have a
placeholder
of uh enter your message
sure and then we need to close out the
form
now phoenix does have the ability to do
all this within
like a do block um where you don't have
to
manually close out the form but phoenix
live view the way it tracks things
is um it essentially needs this f
variable to be able to know when things
have changed
uh within the the web page and render it
re-render them
um correctly helpfully um
not sure what the right word for that
would be but to do it very efficiently
um so we need to do it that way um so
now we have our chat
text box here which is lovely so um i
want to chat so what happens if we like
hit enter here
and uh you know what's gonna so we see
you can mention you saw that spinning
wheel and it crashed
if go back to our logs here our server
logs you can see that
it crashed and the reason was because we
don't have a handle event submit message
just like when we had that
um the click for the um
the button to start up the um
or to go to the random webpage random
chat room
we don't have the ability to uh to
submit the message quite yet
and i really hope the stream is coming
through okay i keep seeing on my
presenting software that
um my uh my kill bits per second goes
down to zero occasionally so if you're
getting stutters or
the stream is dropping out i really
apologize i'm not sure what that is
um but hopefully it's fine on your end
and my obs software is just
lying to me because when has software
never lied to you
all right we need to define the handle
event submit message so let's do that
um and that's going to be inside our
page live i'm sorry room live
this is implementation uh so we're gonna
say
deaf handle event and our event is
submit message
and then it's gonna have params in this
case we do care about the params because
that's gonna be
the forum when this submit message is
called or sent
it's going to to grab all the
information from the form
and send that on with the the message so
we do have a chat we named the form
itself chat and then within that chat
form we have a field
called messages i'm sorry message so we
can say message
is we can we can um uh
basically pattern match that message to
grab it as we define the function itself
and then of course we always have the
socket come along as well
for now let's just log out the message
so log info
message was message and
again we're going to say no reply and
send the socket straight on through
now i think i probably have um
one too few closing parentheses no
okay we should be good all right let's
um submit a message now
and see what happens a message
hit enter so we see it didn't crash we
still have our message
in the box here if we go to our terminal
we can see that we do have message
a message so we are receiving that
message fine now what do we need to do
with that message right
we need to um uh broadcast that message
out to all the people who are currently
subscribed to
the um to the webpage i'm wondering
should we
maybe we should do this in a different
uh different order like what if we
um instead of worrying about multiple
users first
let's just worry about um
well actually we can do both the same
time all right we're going to to do this
um on mount we're going to do something
special here
that that phoenix provides now um
i mentioned that phoenix live view
is basically using sockets and channels
to
to do the communication between client
and server side and um
it's built in already into phoenix and
phoenix live view essentially builds on
top of what's already provided
to make things really easy to configure
but
we're going to tap into that power
ourselves and
um and do some of our own subscribing
and and
uh broadcasting things like that
so um the ideas
the the idea of a channel is basically
that there's a topic
and um you can subscribe to a topic and
anytime
a message is sent out from that topic or
to the subscribers of that topic then
we'll need to handle
that message as a topic listener um so
first let's
define a variable or assign a variable
topic
um and it'll say room and then um
we'll append the room id to the room so
in this case our topic would be what was
our our topic would be room colon
panther silk empire special um let's
change this since this is
just again remember we can we can put
anything in here as the id so
if i put in just phoenix in action
phoenix in action
now we have a chat room dynamically
created for us called phoenix in action
so the the channel would be named room
or sorry to the topic would be named
room colon phoenix in action so let's do
that um that's going to be a room id
and um chatweb
defines something called the endpoint
and the endpoint um
within the endpoint we can subscribe to
topics uh so this is we're gonna say
we're gonna subscribe to this topic
and um our endpoint will take care of
all
the um the leavings the goings the
subscribings the
the unsubscribes the message passing all
that's going to be handled for us
um within the endpoint which is really
nice um and we're also gonna
let's go ahead and send the topic along
into our signs
so that later like in other events later
on we can
pull that topic out of the assigns and
we don't have to keep um
recomputing it it'll just be
within the socket which is nice and then
um
let's go ahead and set up something
that tracks our messages uh so let's say
messages
um hello manning uh how about hello
twitch hello twitch
uh so that's gonna be our messages i'm
gonna put this in a list for now i'm
gonna set array
uh and a list for now save that
um and now what are we gonna do with
that so we're not doing anything with
the topic we're not doing anything
with the messages and even though we've
subscribed to
um the topic we haven't done anything in
terms of
uh sending messages to that topic um but
we'll do that in there in a second for
now let's go back to our uh
our html and uh chat where it says chat
goes here let's do
um let's actually put out the messages
or list out the messages so we'll say
for message
in messages and again we have the little
at symbol because
we've assigned this to the socket so
it's available within the view template
we are going to um
let's say let's put it up in a p and uh
put an
id id there we go
um and the message since it's going to
have it have to have an id
let's let's define
what a message is going to look like um
let's not do that yet we're not going to
worry about ids i'll show you why we
need an id in a little bit but for now
we don't need it so let's not
let's not complicate things so we're
just going to put out the message which
is just the string
and then let's close out our end here
and close out our
four all right what does that look like
all right so now we have hello twitch
that's our first message um
within uh the messages assigned so we
can add another one here
um how are things
and then that should show up underneath
hello twitch because we're rendering out
all the messages
so one of the things we want to do is
again i want to make this look a little
bit better
can we um let's not do that yet let's
not do that
all right um instead of hello let's just
say something like
um twitch joined the chat
and we'll leave it at that all right
because i would like it to have
um the ability to as people leave or go
leave or join it'll give us messages
like you know geo joined the chat or
richard left the chat kelly joined the
chat
um things like that so let's keep it
right there for now
so now let's handle what happens if
someone sends a message like if i type
something in here
hit enter we're doing nothing the
message is being received by our process
here in room live but it's not been
doing anything except for logging it out
but we want to do something more
so i mentioned earlier that this chat
web endpoint we're subscribing to the
topic right now
but we're not really doing anything to
it for now we can say chatweb.endpoint
and we could broadcast
to the topic so we put that in our sign
so we could get it out here
so socket the science topic
um do we name it topic yeah we named it
topic in that room okay good
so um the second thing um is going to be
the event that we're broadcasting in
this case we're going to say hey a
message received so a new message was
sent
um and then the um
the value or basically the payload let's
call the payload so
the message is going to be the payload
and that's again just the string for it
for the moment
um perfect and so no reply socket's
still going to be good
so when we broadcast this we should see
something interesting
uh so hello hit enter
again we see the spinny blue ball and it
crashed
look in our logs we crashed why'd we
crash right
without we're handling everything well
when we we subscribe to the topic
of the room we are in and then we send a
message to that topic
but we haven't handled that message um
and messages
uh like this these broadcast messages
are handled within handle info
function so we need to find this handle
info with this
event information in it as well that
should be too hard so we'll imple true
def handle info and we can pattern match
on the message
which was a new message no sorry the
event
not message message on my mind
new message and you can see the next
thing within this
um struct of the phoenix socket
broadcast the next thing was
payload which was which had the message
in it so
payload the payload key has our message
what else do we need from there we have
the topic of the room topic which
we don't need in this situation um and
then we have the socket itself
which of course we are going to need so
let's take the socket
and do something in here so we can say
let's just log this out again
um let's say payload this time to
make it a little bit different than the
other and again we're not going to reply
but we are going to pass the socket on
as it was all right so now when we
submit a message we should see
a logger info here for message of the
message and then
it's going to broadcast that out to all
the the listeners
the subscribers to the topic which we
are one
so we should see another info of payload
with that same message let's see if
that's what we actually get
uh do you hear me
all right looks like something happened
yes we have message do you hear me and
payload do you hear me perfect that is
what we wanted
um so we have that now so what do we do
with it well we can
append that to the list of messages and
then
phoenix is smart enough to know that
that messages has changed
so it will then re-render all it reads
to render
um to um
to make the page work i can't think of a
better way to say it
it makes the page work um so
how are we gonna do that for now right
now okay remember we're looping through
we're iterating through the messages
um and so we want to append that to the
list of messages so let's do that
um so instead of log or just logging yet
we're going to assign this to the socket
um our messages and
in this case we're going to say the
socket assign so what's in messages
right now
um and then tack onto that the new
message
all right so this little i call it the
um
the guillotine operator it's
it's not the name of it but i like to
think of it like that because it
separates the head from the tail so this
basically says
pull the messages in there first and
then also the the new message
um although this isn't gonna work quite
right so let's do something a little
different let's instead of this way
let's just
do this appending there
like that that'll tackle on to the end
all right so let's say did you get
this okay so it's nothing something
something did go wrong um key message
not found
in oh because it's messages yeah
so messages on this one
plus the new message all right that'll
reload
um hello all right so now we have hello
showing up on our messages because
again phoenix tracks the state of
the signs in the slot in the socket
recognizes that there has been a change
in the messages assigned
and then re-renders just that part of
the html
in fact if we look at the um
at the network requests let's see
um let's do another one another
oh you know what i need to reload to get
this websocket connection
and i think it might be this one
response
okay so if we say hello
so it sent that um request response
that's just maybe is this one
yeah here we go
uh yeah so you can see that uh in this
message it did send both of our messages
because that is the messages assigned it
also has this form
um because we're not doing things super
efficiently with the form but that's
okay for what we're doing today
uh so again all it sent was this hello
which is super nice well and this twitch
during the chat but we're gonna
you may be thinking well what if you
have like a million messages and every
time
what you're doing is you're appending
the new message to the list of a million
messages
that's not going to scale well and you
are correct good for you you get the
gold star
but instead we want to do something well
phoenix already thought of that too
so um the way that phoenix thought of
that is it's like well
this is going to happen we need a way to
deal with that because it stores the
assigns in a process and that process is
long running so that's still going on
on my server it's just keeping track of
this process as my
my browser is connected
oh another very important thing about
our chat application that i forgot to
mention that's going to come into play
here is
if you're not there when the chat is
sent then you don't see that message
so it's not like slack where it's got
the history there is no history that's
why there's no database there's no users
it's like it's like if the tree falls in
the force no one's around to hear it
it doesn't make a sound in this case it
makes no sound um
there's no one to hear it it's like it
never existed it's ephemeral it's
gone it's never it was like it's never
gone never there in the first place
so um phoenix handles this through
something called
temporary assigns temporary assigns so
in here we can tell it which assigns
we're considering temporary in this case
messages is temporary
and once it uses the value of messages
we have to tell it what to basically
reset that value back to so in this case
we want it back to an empty array sorry
empty list
let me save that should reformat a
little bit better there we go
um so what's it going to do so phoenix
is going to take
the initial value of messages here which
is going to have which has you know
twitch join the chat
it's going to go to our html and iterate
through all our messages
and uh print out the message in our
little p tag here
and once it's done doing that it knows
hey i've done
what i need to do with this message is
assigned so i'm going to then
throw it away basically i'm going to
reset it to this temporary state of
messages equals an empty array
now if you think about it you're like
well we have to
now if i type in hello um
well that still comes through because we
have the size messages
did that save maybe i didn't save that
let's try it oh i did save it
hello okay well didn't do what i thought
i was going to do
which i thought was going to erase
everything in the messages
because now we only have that one
message but
um now we want to when it receives a new
message to
um just put that new message into the
into the
list of messages because that's the only
one that we now care about
so in here
if we do that now hello
you can see that it takes the place of
the previous message
and that's not what we want either um
but again phoenix has thought of that
so within this chat messages it has this
phoenix update
callback or attribute
and it says whenever phoenix receives an
update for this div what do we do with
it now the default is replaced so it'll
just replace that whole div with the new
information um
and and go from there but instead of
replace we want to append
that's another option for phoenix update
plus a pre-pin and a couple others that
are all covered in the documentation
which is excellent by the way
uh someone to append that means just pop
it at the end of the whatever list you
already had going
um and that should be good so hello
um that did not do it either
so let's see here we do have our message
hello
um and
i'm not sure why we don't
have the list of messages anymore
because we're going to sprinkle message
let me just make sure we're still
getting
this payload a message
all right send a message here
and yeah we are getting the payload okay
interesting so let's figure this out why
is this
uh coming through in this manner um what
we can do is we can actually
log out the the current state of
messages also it's interesting that
for now the um
the message is like when i reload the
page so if i read the page
you can see that this says twitch during
the chat but it goes away real quick
i don't know if you can see that uh
through the stream but reload it's there
and it's gone
so we gotta figure out why that is um
because that should not that should not
be happening either
um so let's
think about this it might be that i
put in the wrong um phoenix update
tell you what let's go to those
excellent docs i was mentioning and
check it out so
let me see dash
and then uh nothing here but we want
uh there's a guide for handling form
bindings in here
so um uh you know what that is phoenix
change
for events no we don't want form events
we just want uh regular binding so
go back to the live view docs so phoenix
live view
and then down here we can see
bindings all right so we have
click events form events focus blend
events
key events uh which is cool to handle
like uh keyboard shortcuts which is
pretty neat
uh former events form or phoenix change
but dom patching is phoenix update
um so i think we should have uh
we did have it right phoenix update i'm
wondering if i put it in the wrong
dom so we have replace ignore append and
prepend
um and this might be
where the the id thing i was talking
about earlier might come into play
uh it goes through and talks about how
you know we do have temporary signs oh
it's got messages
as well um and
uh let's see now whenever there are more
than one or more new messages we'll sign
only the new messages to messages um
in the template we wrap went to wrap all
the messages in a container
and tag this content with phoenix update
remember we must add an id to the
container as well
as to each child so that's the reason
it's not coming through is because
we're not attaching an id to the child
and i should have added it earlier i
know he's going to get into the trouble
but for now let's just say it's the
message itself so the id
is the string of the message which as
you can imagine will also get some
trouble later because what if you put in
the same
message twice but now at least we'll be
able to see hello be appended to our
list of messages and we know that
um uh
thanks from um yes there's the uh if
connected he mentioned that or um
thump mentioned that there is an if
connected uh thing you can do so you can
say if connected socket that we can do
some things
uh do you know hi um but for now
we don't need to do that we can if we
wanted within the
subscribe so um
so if connected instead of socket then
we can
do this subscribe subscribe to the topic
but in this case the issue was the id
um oh if connected
there we go okay back to being good
um now we need to do something a little
better than just handling the id as the
message itself
so um there's another package that we
can use called uh uuid that's just like
simple let's just generate something
completely random
um 1.8 is the current thing so again we
need to
reshape the server because we're going
to break it install those dependencies
dips.gip and
that's done so let's restart the server
it's going to compile those things
there's a few warnings within the uid
package itself but we don't really care
about those at the moment
so now we're going to start talking
about um handling the message
in a in some sort of structure because
right now it's just the string but we're
going to need some more information
about it like that uuid
so what can we do we can do a few
different things we can create its own
module we can
that would basically be its own struct
that would might be
the smarter thing long term short term
let's
do something um a little
faster so we can just say uid and uid
has
a i think it's uuid for function we'll
see if that blows up
actually let's check it in the iex
session uid uid4
yeah cool that gives us the id so we're
gonna have this random id
um and then uh in the uid key within our
map here
and then we'll have maybe just like the
maybe content
content yeah this is called content
content
um and let's do that save that
now it's going to blow up because in our
html we have we're not handling
um into that map we're just saying that
we're just handling if
it was a string so we do need to handle
it as
a as the map so for each message now the
id
is going to be the message uid and uh
the
the
printed content is going to be message
content
save that uh we should now get messages
again
but again if i um type a message
we'll we'll crash again because we're
not handling the correct message type in
this handle event let me
kill out these loggers and instead of a
new message
with just passing on the string we can
say the message is going to be
this map here and again we're going to
need a uid
uh duid4
and then the content is going to be the
message which again is the string that
we're receiving from the form
so we're going to pass that on as the
message or broadcast
that as the message uh so now
everything's hooked up correctly again
and now we have the uuid
uh handled as well which is nice let me
make this a little bit bigger there we
go
no reason to waste that screen space
that sweet sweet screen space
all right thank you for um for going
through that with me that was quite the
journey
but we did it all right what's next
what if um each user that comes in like
right now i can type hello
um oh by the way let me bring up another
page here the browser window and show
you that this is already
handling multiple connections localhost
4000.
oh yeah and we wanted to go to the
phoenix inaction chat room because
that's where all the action is happening
uh i'm here too
sweet so you can see that i entered it
here um
and we got it on the initial uh browser
which is what we wanted you can also see
that
as i mentioned this hello was sent
during this
session's lifetime but not during this
session's lifetime so this session on
the right has no clue that that happened
earlier which is kind of what we want we
want to be like if you're not here for
the party then you don't get to see what
happened
uh let me just uh keep this over to the
side
i don't know how that's going to look
but
sure let's try that one big one small
now another thing you may mention is or
you may see is
as i'm you know entering messages here
that
the um content
that text area content or text input
content doesn't change doesn't go away
there's a few different things we can do
to handle that um and i originally
planned on handling that later but it's
just gonna annoy me that it
doesn't go away so let's handle it now
right
this is the again the two different ways
we could do it um that i could think of
there's probably others
is we can actually write a javascript
hook
um that will listen for events and
um and clear out this input as uh
as it's submitted um again i
really wanted to do this whole thing
without writing any javascript so we're
not gonna do it that way
instead we're going to hook into another
um
another hook that phoenix provides so
again or if you remember we had this in
this form we had this phoenix submit
submit message
but we also can have phoenix update and
that means every time any
and every time anything in this form
changes uh send this
message to the process the handling
process um
so we can say uh i don't know form
updated
all right so then we need to handle that
right um so we have the submit message
event handled uh so implementation true
handle events uh what did i call it form
update
let's not say update and say update now
what do we want to do on the update
um again we have the chat form and
within there we have the messages
text field and we can call that message
and then the socket of course
always and
we can basically track the value of
that form so let me show you let's again
let's log
out here uh the message
message and we don't do a no reply
and just pass on the socket as it is so
nothing's gonna happen in here except
for locking it out
so now um let me see if i can
uh what's the best way to do this i'll
go this
up a little bit all right so now when
i type a message every time i type a
letter we should see something going on
the logs
and we don't perfect are we getting that
message
probably not because we're not logging
that info out
um save that reload
all right is it form update or phoenix
update
no it's phoenix change i think it was
yeah not a phoenix update it's phoenix
change
all right let's try it out
if you're like familiar with phoenix
you're probably shaking your fist at me
right now
um all right what we have a crash here
why is that because we're not handling
the event correctly we have form update
uh the csr token we don't care about
that oh chat message and then that so
what are we not um handling correctly it
must be something in here that i'm doing
uh oh i'll do messages so again
i mentioned that elixir does pattern
matching on
the um on the functions so in this case
it tried to match the complete pattern
we gave it which was
chat and within the chat map there's a
messages key
and within the messages key there's a
message value but there is no messages
key
it's called message uh so let's try it
now
all right so we have the log down below
and as we type yeah you can see that the
message
continues to build as we type
and that's what we want because then
what we can do
is um when
we submit the message the chat message
we can reset
this assign we can assign first of all
we need to make an assign
so we can assign the message string so
you can say message equals blank
and in here we have this text input
message and it actually uses the value
of the assigns in this case it's going
to be message which is going to be
helpful for us it could be confusing if
you didn't know that that's happening
but that's uh that's what we're going to
do and so
then we can say form update message
message
we're going to assign
to the socket message is going to be
the current con the current value of
what's in the message text field
and then over the text input we need to
tell it
that uh what the value of it is so again
let me look in the documentation
for text input see which one that is
text input here
we have form field options um
see the form should either be a form
emitted by form 4 or an atom
all given options are 4 to 2 to the
underlying input default values provided
for id
name and value if possible so let's try
value so placeholders forwarded on and
value
also be forwarded on so value equals
message
all right let's see what that does
hello um and then
uh let's do form submit so when we
submit the message we also
um right now we're just passing the
socket on but instead we want to reset
the message assign to a blank string
now let's cross our fingers and see if
this works
hello yeah okay perfect
so basically um it's if you're familiar
with react it's kind of like a
controlled input now
um to where we're telling it what the
value is it just happens to be that
whatever we type is going to the server
setting and assign the assign is going
back to our view and saying this is now
your value as an input
um the javascript way probably is the
the faster a better way but again i
wanted to do this stream without writing
any javascript just to say we could do
that
so sweet now we need users
okay let's generate some users
to do that um
let's generate a user so the user is
going to be
the mnemonic slugs again and
we can say
generate slug not generated slug
generate slug let's just say two
um and the username is going to be the
username
so let's change this from user to
username
um
so let's say instead of twitch around
the chat let's say username join the
chat and see if that works
i think generates i think i got the the
manaomic slugs thing right yeah so
in this case i am agent deliver oh
that's pretty sweet name
um and over here on the right is tripod
history
um so since the user's not picking their
username let's let them know who they're
chatting at so up here in our
top right we see the html of what's
being generated um so we're saying
currently chatting in the room id
and then we can say like i don't know as
like the strong again and then the
username
close out that strong
all right and find function username
because i didn't put a
ampersand or like a symbol in front of
that it's
not a local variable alright so now we
are currently chatting in phoenix in
action as
child arctic sweet and on the right it's
screen arrow
alright so charlotte child architect
joined the chat and screen arrow join
the chat
those again if you remember those are
just statically generated
based on the current user who they are
at the moment um but we need to do
something a little more
uh dynamic let's say because if like if
another person joins like if we go and
join again um all right we want the
phoenix in action chat room
phoenix in action
uh so phoenix dispute joined the chat
but these two you know screen arrow and
child arc
arctic doesn't don't know about phoenix
dispute yet wow phoenix
how strange that phoenix came up as a
random name that's pretty fun
all right bye phoenix defeat dispute um
so we want to be able to track those as
well
so how do we do that um let's do that
through
presence let's get into presents um
no let's not get into presence yet but
instead let's check let's
um track who uh submitted the message
so if i press sdf i know i typed that
but over here in
a screen arrow's screen he doesn't know
that child arctic is the one who typed
that
so that's one more piece of metadata we
need to track within our assign
or sorry our map here that's checking
the message contents
so we have uuid we have the content
let's also put the username in here
for now let's just say username system
for this
initial message but eventually this mess
this
initial message is going to go away but
for now let's just say that because it's
going to need something
um and so for this message the username
is in our socket so we can say socket
assigns
uh username and it's going to broadcast
that message
and it's going to pass that on to the
view template
uh and we can handle it there so instead
of just message content let's say
um the username
type in the username put out the
username
oh it's the message username right not
the assigns username it's the message
username
close out that strong and then a colon
and then the message content
all right so now we have system row
scorpio join the chat so if i
enter a message over here as rose
scorpio then press sample over here on
the right should see that this message
is
for me or from me um hi
i'm rose sweet so now we have
um we know who is actually sending this
message
so press sample um hi
rose uh
i'm sample
cool now both know who each other
what what they're talking about um if
you're if you've not joined us for a
little while thanks for
for joining in uh midway my name is
jeffrey lessel i wrote phoenix in action
let me just go through this again i want
a few places online
um twitter is at geolessel and then i've
got
a blog at jeffreylessel.com i haven't
done anything with it for a while but
there's still some good content up there
about ecto
and elixir uh and then i
do some youtube streaming as well um at
youtube.com
c geolessel i've been doing some um
emacs stuff
recently uh but i'm hoping to do more
elixir stuff on there as well soon
so join me there also if you're watching
and you want anything from manning.com
uh at 40 off then today's your lucky day
because you can just type in twit
less 40 to get 40 off everything at
manning.com
including phoenix in action let me show
you this if you go i made it really easy
i put up a read act if you just go to
phoenix in action
uh if i spell it right phoenix
inaction.com it'll take you right there
it'll take you right to manning's page
add it to your cart enter twit less 40
to get 40
off and if you go to this particular url
i'll just get a little bit more
for it um and that will help me out i
really appreciate it
um so thank you for doing that let me go
back to
uh coding let's get back to it thanks
for allowing me to do that and thanks
for showing up by the way i really i
really do appreciate it it's kind of fun
being here
again if you have any questions or
anything like that you want to see
something specific put it in chat
um i i did find a way to pop out that
chat so i don't have to
do watch the stream and stream at the
same time because that was you know my
eyes are starting to water
doing that but i can't see your chat so
that's good
all right so we have the ability to
track who sent the message
um and print that out on anyone who
subscribed to this page
or who's logged into the page or not
logged in but who's open to this page
because they are subscribed to that
topic now
let's get into tracking um
presence because that's pretty fun when
i first saw how easy presence was
in phoenix my mind was kind of blown um
and because i'm like that i'm just going
to pull out this form
into the out here because
i didn't like the way it looked inside
inside there
so that doesn't look any better it looks
pretty nasty
but yeah it looks well maybe it looks
better let's say it looks better let's
pretend
you and i let's pretend let's play
pretend that that is better
it actually will look better when we put
in um
the uh the box for the users so let's
build that box just to make it look
better for now so
um in here let's say div id equals
uh user list maybe um
and then for now let's just say you know
user one
and user two
let's do that and click the div and uh
let's see what that looks like we're
going to do some
css because remember we did this as
a flex
column i believe it was let me go back
to my css
app css uh yeah flex direction
column so let's delete that this should
put it side by side
it does which is good um
let's put the border on chat messages
uh so then we need the margin on chat
messages too
there we go so the users are on the on
the right um
and let's uh put in like a h2 like an h3
users online
yeah again this isn't a css session
as you can plainly see
but we'll say this is good enough for us
all right
um i did lose some of my my padding um
inside my chat messages which i do like
let's do that all right cool
boom hire me as your next designer
okay moving on let's do presents
what is presence presence is something
built into phoenix
that uses um
i forgot the the acronym i guess let's
go to presents here in the docs which
again are
excellent uh phoenix presents
it does it with um
oh shoot i forgot it was called it's not
in here i thought i mentioned the the
crazy
word it used to uh to do the presence
over multiple
servers but anyway it was just some
protocol to handle
um distributed uh presence tracking so
that when a user logs in
that user is tracked not tracked in the
sense of like we want to know where
they're going so we can sell them ads
but more like
is this user online and active on this
particular topic
and the what we can do with that is like
if if a user logs in with their cell
phone
and on the web you can we can know that
they're active on their phone but maybe
inactive on the web
um and then we can actually if for some
reason like their account
get cancelled or something like that we
can kick them out of all those sessions
um which is pretty cool we can also the
way we're going to use it today
is we're going to have a user list of
see who's ever who who all is online at
the moment
so we can see who we might be chatting
with
over on the right hand side there all
right so
um excuse me we do need to do a few
different
things
to um to set this up let me just uh
look at something real quick the easiest
thing to do
is um phoenix provides a
generator for presence so let's just use
that so mix
i think it's phynxgen presents
let's see if that's it yeah there it is
okay so it generated this file for us
um in channels presence.ex and then it
says add your new module to your
supervision tree
in libchat application that's what i
love about elixir it's like you could be
you could know like nothing about what's
going on and
it'll usually give you pretty good
indication about what you need to do
next
so here's our children in our
application this basically starts all
our
supervision tree which means that
anything in here is supervised
which means if it goes down for one
reason or another then phoenix will try
to start it back up or application will
try to start it back up in the last
known good state
which is pretty sweet so we can say it
was chatweb dot
presence easy enough so we need to add
that to a supervision tree as well
so that it'll start it up on startup of
our application and also track it and
supervise it make sure it's alive and
healthy as it goes
all right so let's restart our server
and
our presence will be started
automatically for us but let's look in
that presence file it generated for us
just to see what's in there it's super
small
i mean this is all it is for now it uses
phoenix presence and it has our otp app
that's uh the app of our our phoenix
application's name is chat
and then the pub sub server that we're
using is uh chat up hub sub
and again this is something that was
generated automatically for us when we
started up phoenix with the the phoenix
generator
all right now that we have it let's use
it um to use it
whoa i'm going to close a window not
start one we need to do something to
mount here
and uh let's expand this if connected so
instead of just one thing
we're gonna do a couple different things
um first of all we're going to subscribe
to the topic but we're also going to
uh announce our presence that's a good
way to say it
we're just going to tell presents we
want to start tracking it and we're
going to say
you know chatweb.presence
and they have it has a track function
and let's look at the documentation the
track function here
uh it says track an arbitrary process as
a presence same with track three except
track any process by topic and key
so if we look at track three um up here
track a channel's process as a presence
track presences are grouped by key
cast as a string for example to group
each user's channels together
use user ids as keys each presence can
be associated with a map of metadata to
store small ephemeral state such as the
user's online status
to store detailed information see fetch
we don't need detailed information at
the moment
um but what we do want to do is
uh group the user's channels by their
username in this case the usernames are
random so um it shouldn't matter too
much
that uh well
it there could be collisions but in our
case we don't
really care about the collisions um that
much because
it's probably it's improbable there'll
be collisions within the same room
especially since the rooms themselves
are random um it could happen
this is just a toy application anyway
but if you're if you decide to make the
next slack
uh then you might want to handle um
these potential collisions
and have logins and usernames if we did
have like logins and usernames or set
user names um then that wouldn't be an
issue uh at all but
for now we're going to say for for this
process that's what self means
and for the topic of the room and the
room id
we're going to track the key of user
name and then
this map is the extra metadata we want
to store about
about this particular user in this case
we don't have anything in there
let me save that so now every time or
when the um the page loads
here
all right that is reloading a lot
because we're getting error messages
that's what i was going to say next but
it beat me to it um
we need to handle this so all right let
me
let me stop the server just so you can
see this um
in room live here what is what is this
air image is getting why are we getting
this error message
um because you can see that we're
getting another message being sent to
our uh our page live or sorry room live
and that message is this event of
presence diff now what is presence diff
if you look back in the documentation at
the very top here
um let's go down here so here's how he
presents track here's like
um what happens it says finally a diff
of presence join and leave events will
be sent to the client as they happen in
real time
with the presence diff event the disc
structure will be a map of joins and
leaves of the
form got a map joins is the key and then
each one of these
is the key of the uh the thing being
tracked in this case it's our username
and these are the metas we can again we
can store meta information here we
haven't
uh in this case but it all it includes
this phoenix ref for us automatically
but we don't store anything on any other
information but we what we want to do
is know or handle this presence diff
because it's sent
to us as we join the channel um since we
joined it
it seems weird that we get the message
as well but if you think about it it's
not odd
it's not that odd because everything is
as a message
we're trying to make everything a
message to and from the client and the
server
so in this case the client um joins or
mounts
the the socket the the page and
um in mount here uh we're doing all this
amount
um we are starting to track the presence
and once
again once the presence receives that
track message
then um it sends out a diff message to
all everyone that's subscribed to this
particular topic
or this particular um well yeah topic
and that includes the client that's
currently connected so we need to handle
that
uh so let's go down here and add another
um
handle of info so it's another
implementation handle info
uh in this case it's events and the
event name is
uh presence diff
and let me just verify that it's
presents diff and not diff presence it
is present stiff okay
and the payload has joins
let's just call that joins and it also
has leaves and let's
uh bind that to leaves um
and that's all i care about in the event
and of course it sends the socket along
with it as well
now for now let's just do a no reply so
we don't just get the the crazy reloads
all the time
because the crash and reload save that
let me reshape the server
and now we should
be able to load the page without it
completely crashing on us
it is taking a little while to actually
finish that load and i'm not
exactly sure why i may have more uh old
information in
the session um
okay well we'll go with that for now but
we do need to handle this presence diff
um so how we're going to handle this
present stuff so let's um what do we
want to do
when a user leaves or joins the first
thing we want to do
is we'd like to send a specific type of
message
to the chat client so that we can say
you know
x user joined or x user left so let's do
that
first um all right
so we have joins we have leaves let's do
a logger info
of joins just see what's in there and
then leaves see what's in there as well
save that and um
it's going to reload so we can see here
we have some join so we have topic split
was the username that joined and then we
seen this met as we do have the phoenix
ref
which again we're not using but we
didn't we also didn't provide any other
metas
and we also have chef define which
joined and uh
it's in it loaded twice because of um
i think because it's reloaded and then
automatically mounted
from the auto reload all right so what
are we gonna do for both of those
well first we want to um
create a message for each of those
so let's do this let's say
we have joins we have leaves
those are two separate um
excuse me two separate maps
um and each of those maps has
the username i would like to reduce
all those down to just a a list of
messages that we can then send to the
clients
so what would be the best way to do that
um
well let's kind of do it um a quick and
dirty way first and then if we want to
we can come back and refactor it but
let's just see if we can make it work
so messages is going to equal and we're
going to take joins first
and for each of the joins i'm sorry the
joins is a map so we need to do
map.keys send that into map keys we get
all the keys of the map which are the
user names
and then that way we can map those and
say uh
it's going to take a function and the
function is going to receive the
username
and then we can create a message um
which the message has a uuid
you got eu id4
and the content um let's say it's going
to be
username joined
like that um i think that's all we need
for now
yeah the username there isn't a username
um
so that's going to crash when we first
do it but we'll take care of that here
in a minute
because well we could have the usb
system let's let's make it system for
now
just so it won't crash username is
system
okay so those are our messages with
joins and then we can also
we can say we call this join messages
and then we can also create a leave
messages
messages equals and then really the same
thing so
leaves pipe that into map.keys because
that gives us the user names
and then we can email map function
that's the username
and then it's going to have a uid the id
4.
the content is going to be username
uh left and then username is going to be
system okay
let me end that um
whoops i forgot to close out the map not
that one
over here
okay so now in our socket
we want to assign to the socket messages
and now our messages are going to be
those joins join messages
plus the leave messages
and uh let's see what that gives us
all right go back to our web page we do
have um
the system messages coming so we'd say
that salon service joined and then
genetic finish joined so uh looks like
we're getting those correctly let's open
up a new one
uh localhost 4000 phoenix in action
here's the chat room uh and then screen
drama yeah so we have screen drama joins
uh so now we have presence tracking at
least so if let's like screen drama
leave yeah so screenshot on the left you
see how quick that was by the way
it's one of the cool things about
presents is it's super fast and
performant
so everyone knows now that screen drama
you know popped in take a look around i
was like this is a
dumpster fire and left
he is no longer with us all right what
do we want to do now
let's um let's build out this users
online
um before we do that let me go back to
the css
and for the chat messages
let's say chat messages uh
any paragraphs and chat messages let's
set those margins to zero and the
padding to zero
just make things a little squishier
there we go that looks a little better
for me
to my eye and we also want to take out
remember we had this initial
messages array of uh one of those
messages
let's take that out completely and just
have
let presence track the joins and the uh
the leaves
that's looking good okay next thing is
these uh the user tracking
now um we know when a user joins
and we know when a user leaves because
we have this handle info presence diff
[Music]
and um you know what let's do something
a little bit different here
um let's
have a type a message type uh in this
case we're gonna have
this is gonna be a system message type
so it's gonna come from the
this the system and it's not gonna have
a username
um and then down here this also is not
gonna have a username
but it is going to have a type
it's a system type okay and i'm doing
this because i kind of want to use
an interesting i'll show you some an
interesting thing about
the ability to pattern match and you'll
notice that it's just reloading itself
because
it's crashing because there is no
username um and it thinks that there
should be a username
um so we need to take care of that it's
just going to keep crashing itself and
reloading itself until we fix that so
let's be nice to it and fix it back to
our html
we are trying to take out the message
username which in this case is
nothing but instead of
instead of this p tag here what if we
[Music]
created a function called uh
i don't know display message
display message and it's going to do
that for the message
um let's delete the rest of that and
that's gonna be the whole thing so now
it's gonna crash for a whole different
reason because we haven't defined
display message
um and since we're in the process since
again remember
each uh page that's loaded and
running is a process within um
within phoenix so the the message is
gonna be called to the process itself
uh or on the process itself so we need
to find display message in here
now here's where the pattern matching is
gonna come in inside the message there's
gonna be two different types of structs
they're not really struck two different
types of maps one is going to have the
type
of system and the other is not so we can
pattern match here so type system so
whenever there is a
a message that comes through as a
parameter with a parameter with
and inside that map has the type of
system then this is the the function
definition that's going to
going to uh to match um in this case we
also
want the uuid so we can um
grab that and we also want the content
so let's grab that as well
we can just bind all that right in the
function declaration
and then here's um the
content we pulled out let's just say
like that i need to put out
to put a new line there okay
save that um this is only going to match
for the first one but then we could say
for any other display message that has
no type
um we can say we all we need is the uuid
and the contents and this actually have
this backwards and the
um username
user name
do this is actually what's gonna be
displayed for
messages from users and we need to do
something else for messages with
um without users for now i'm going to
display nothing just to see just to make
sure that our um
our other display is working correctly
so this should
um display a message and it does not so
let's make sure that this is being done
correctly i think is it e
uh no
unfind function message so there's
something oh right
um it's not message.ud and it's not
message.username
and it's not message.content
it's just i already pattern matched
those out
hello okay cool so that is working again
so now we need to handle those system
messages which is up here
for those let's make it look pretty
similar to this
um but instead of
a strong let's put like an m and we
don't use your name
let's just say that uh the content there
is gonna be like that and then close out
the m so that should be
like um italics
let's see what that does yeah so ali
broken alibi broken join and circus
segment joined and then our normal
messages should look
normal yeah cool okay
and then anytime we get any other
message type that doesn't match one of
these two
it'll it'll blow up on us which we kind
of want it to do we want to be loud so
we know
how to handle it in the future um which
is good so now we need to go to
that user list so we know how to handle
the joins and the leaves which is
up here and if you look back in the
documentation it actually has this get
by key
the presence module has this git by key
function
this function returns the map of
presence metadata for a socket
topic key pair in this case um
well you can see the example here get by
key room
one and user one so we in the assigns we
know we stored the the topic and we
stored the the username which are the
two things we need because we also
told presence to track it by the topic
and by username as the key so we can use
this git by key
and see all the current information
about the users um
as as well as they are so
let's um let's use that in this handle
info present stuff because the the time
we need to
update the user list is the time when
the presence diff comes through
right because anytime a user leaves or
joins
this presence diff message will be sent
and that's when we need to update our
list
so let's just say let's just bind this
to user list equals
chatweb presence
and then get by key was the function
name
and again we do have the socket which
also has the assigns so we have the
topic in there
and also in there we all have the
username
of the current user who owns the socket
all right so for now i'm just going to
log out that user list to show you what
it looks like
user list user list and you'll see
there's some information in there we
don't need
in fact there's some information in
there
that um well
let's say it like this in metas you can
see that it's a list because this is
where you can store information about
each connection
for that particular key so let's say we
did have a username
list that you could you could always log
in as geo
then when we looked up geo if i was on
my phone and
in two different browser windows then
geo would have
one key but multiple of these maps
inside of this list because each one of
those tracks
each connection separately which is nice
however
the fact that um
well you know what this this isn't the
function we need
now i'm thinking about it because this
is getting a specific user
we don't need to get to a specific user
we could do something like um
you know how slack has like a geo is
writing type thing like we could we
could track that information in those
metas if we wanted to
uh we're not gonna do that in the stream
we're already like an hour and 45
minutes into the stream so
i'm not going to do that today but we
could instead let's do this list this is
the one we wanted list
this returns president's presences for a
socket topic
and it includes all the keys and in
those the metas
um so not get by key
geo let's just do list and the list
takes
in a uh the socket or the topic um in
this case we need to put in the topic so
socket dot assigns top topic
all right so that should be our user
list now let's go and look at that yeah
so we have dollar ritual
and then since the other page reloaded
as well we also have riviera shrink
and really the keys each of those keys
represents a user
so we can say we can just pull out the
keys and have that be our user list
so let's just pipe that directly into
map.keys and that's our user list
and so we'll also assign that so we have
our messages being assigned let's also
assign a user list
and that will be user list and if we
save this that will now be in the signs
once someone joins
and or and or leaves however we're not
displaying that over here
when we need to display it so we can say
for user in the user list
too and again let's just put it in the p
tag and say user
and the user is going to be a string
because it's that key
and so we don't need anything special to
it
bad formatting okay save that now it'll
crash on us the first time because we
haven't set it up on mount
to track that user list so let's go back
up here
and say um user list is not going to be
in here
user list is going to start out as an
empty array
sorry empty list i've been working in
javascript too much today
all right now we have our online users
um
let me go back in that css before we
look at it too much uh
because i also want to do this to the
user list
user list div yeah
cool all right so now we can join more
users
um let's say localhost 4000
phoenix and action just copy this
so we can put it in so now we have three
users let's add another
now we should have four users yeah so
everyone's getting updates
um and leaves and joins hi everybody
um so quiet oberon is the first one to
speak up uh
and then over here pancake mirage you
know says hi back
hi back um and every every one of the
browser windows gets it
as soon as it happens um which is pretty
pretty cool
uh so then you know quiet oberon leaves
so everyone gets the message that he
left
and our user's online list automatically
updates to show that he's gone
and then we can you know leave uh
pancake mirage can we
have as well so we just left a screen
melody and enigma guest
just us to again
and then the screen melody says yeah but
i like you
all right that
in an hour and 45 minutes is building a
real-time chat application
with phoenix uh live view and um
again i am i am looking at the chat if
you have any questions or comments
please uh put it in there
because i am going to wrap it up here um
thank you for joining me
this was uh it's always interesting to
do stuff live
um because you always encounter error
messages that you haven't before
it's always it's always a treat to see
what comes up
but again if you go to
phoenixinaction.com phoenix
gosh i can't spell today
phoenixinaction.com it'll take you
directly to manning's site
for the phoenix in action book that's
the book i wrote about phoenix
this book came out a couple years ago
and it does not cover live view however
there are some huge things you need to
know before you get into live view that
this book does cover
live view itself came out about
two months after this book was published
and it could take up its own book
and i have been thinking about maybe
doing like some sort of supplements or
appendix or something like that
that um that covers live view a little
bit but live view is its own topic
however
if you're new to elixir or new to
phoenix then this book should get you up
to speed um
to to where you can jump into live view
very easily
and
[Music]
yeah i hope you buy it and also if you
don't know any elixir at all
it's it provides a pretty i think a
pretty thorough
overview of the elixir programming
language enough to get going
i do see some uh some questions here in
the chat the first is
um is phoenix something you would use by
itself or is it primarily for the
real-time socket parts now it's
definitely something that you can use by
itself
i do know that there are plenty of
websites that um
that are served by phoenix that um
aren't really using the live view stuff
at all
i'll show you one thing that i created
it actually does use
uh sockets um but if you're struggling
with regex
and how regular expressions work in
phoenix then this is something you can
use
this was actually created for a
competition when live view was first
announced
um to basically explore
live view and how you can use it but
like first you hear you know you can put
in your input here
so is phoenix something
you would use by itself let's just say
like that
and then you can start putting your
pattern here so let's say you wanted to
match out phoenix and itself uh let's
see if we can do that so
you know as you type not only does um
there was the function call that you
need
in order to you know copy and paste this
this world
of the regex into your own application
code but it also has like the results
and the matches
um which i think is pretty cool so in
between phoenix
and then itself so it doesn't match that
but then we can like
you know pull those parts out so it has
real-time error handling as well
so our first match is phoenix and then
the next thing we wanted to match was
itself um
yeah so we see the match one is phoenix
match two is itself
um so there's things you can do in live
view that
um are really cool and you also see that
you know the
the url itself is being updated in real
time which is is pretty cool i think
so i can like copy and paste this and um
like you can go there
you can see that exact same url or exact
same um
the thing from uh just copy and pasting
it to someone saying hey i found this
regex to work for your situation
um try that out um anyway
uh how that that's an answer to the
question of do you have to use live view
or the the real-time capabilities um you
don't and i will say like
let me show you um
phoenix let's just load the page and uh
the page
loads um when i first loaded the page
here it sent
200 so it sent a good response in four
milliseconds
i mean it connected to the socket in 55
was a microseconds um
phoenix is since it's compiled uh it is
insanely fast so um one of the things
that
phoenix brags about is that it can
handle so many uh simultaneous
connections at one time so if we go to
like i think it's in channels
it talks about the capabilities uh
phoenix channel things you know um
now let's try in the guide for channels
yeah so this just talks about how um
channels works and some
some information about it but then this
uh this i love this paragraph this
architecture scales well
phoenix channels can support millions of
subscribers with reasonable latency
on a single box passing hundreds of
thousands of messages per second
and that capacity can multiply by adding
more nodes to the cluster
one thing that i didn't even go over in
in this particular thing
uh in our chat application is that
it has the ability to um
to do navigation live as well so there's
some uh
some functions that you can use to
handle navigation through the sockets
which means that um when you navigate
from one page to the other if you think
about
normal servers um they basically have
amnesia like they forget
everything about you the moment you
click the next link
that means you've got to send them your
session information and they've got to
re-um revalidate that you are able to
see the page check your permissions
and then re-render like every piece of
html that's
on your page including this phoenix in
action chat header that never changes
or uh the whole javascript bundle that
um that hasn't changed either and so
hopefully there's things that
that they do to to cache that
information but
still that's a lot of information to
send on everything but if you you know
go through live navigation all that um
is is updated
um with very small changes um which is
pretty cool
another thing a little side project that
i've done um that
um right now has a couple errors show up
but i'm gonna show you anyway
uh is um
oh dang i forgot the name of it that
tells you how long it's been since i've
looked at it
um is it flight oh yeah flightcharts.io
um so i'm i'm a pilot and but i also do
a lot of
sim flying and i wanted an easy way to
search for airports and find
flight charts for it from the faa and
you can see that the database
for the faa database hasn't been updated
since uh december so the charts
themselves won't work but you could
still search for airports and
you know identifications names and
cities but watch how fast this
automatic search automatic completion
happens so
let's just say i search for uh san diego
so
if i search sand like all these things
come up this is live view populating
this page in real time
through the search um and then like as i
continue to drill down you can see that
the the page updates so fast
and this is i okay i'll here's
this and um elixir regex and probably
four other side projects are all hosted
on the smallest
um digital ocean
droplet that you can get each in their
own docker container
and while they aren't um
you know they're not huge um
they don't get a whole lot of traffic
they still are
are so fast um that it is very
impressive to me anyway i love phoenix
and what i can provide um
let me show you my website this is not
hosted with phoenix but this is just
straight html but you can see that it's
been a little while since i've
posted something the book took a lot of
my writing energy
but hopefully in there you can find some
things that are very interesting a lot
of things are still
applicable um especially in terms of
ecto and where you can connect to
databases which i didn't cover at all
today
and then also if you go to my youtube
channel i have a playlist
in here um let me uh
let's see wow playlist
let's say as i'm logged in as me you can
see all my my personal playlist but
that's okay
um i have one called
uh where is it talks i've given there it
is
so if you look at talks of given um and
this is linked to from a website maybe
that's how i should have gotten there so
if you go to geoffreylesson.com
uh then talks um here's some
um some of the talks i've given over the
years that you can take a look at
um but in this uh this you know there's
some phoenix information in here that's
pretty fun
um this one is uh phoenix updates
through the browser
i did that it's like a 20 minute talk
did that a meet-up and then i did a
longer version of that
just a couple weeks ago for a go-to conf
and hopefully those will be online soon
but yeah go take a look at those if you
want more information about phoenix and
elixir and some of the fun things you
can do
i like them to dabble with stuff so like
i do stuff like midi devices and
external steering wheel
displays and crazy things like that with
elixir which is really fun
um so yeah thanks cs255 i appreciate
that for the for the question
and for the response um any other
questions from anyone
um happy to answer them
otherwise we're gonna start wrapping
this thing up
um i don't know if it's dinner time for
any of you but it is dinner time for me
and uh i'm getting a little hungry so
let me put this uh screen back up
here um again twitles40
i believe that's like a combination of
twitter and lessel
um i didn't come up with the with the
code manning did
great code uh but twit list is kind of
funny so twit list40 gets you 40
off at manning anything in manning go go
check it out i'm at twitter
at geolessel.com um
not george geolessel
so um like chris mccord who created
elixir
has made some cool stuff including like
a um a twitter clone
uh not a clone that's kind of like a
clone in live view that is really neat
um so yeah go check out my twitter go
check out my github i've got a lot of
things like my dot files on github as
well so if you want to check those out
all right so again you know my um my
twitter
account so message me there if you want
to contact me directly
and uh message me on youtube if you if
you see one of those videos and you want
to get in touch with me let me know
i really appreciate you showing up i do
uh great way to spend a friday afternoon
slash evening
and i'm glad you're here with me uh
again i'm jeffrey lessel
and um thank you so much for joining